i think every single currency is going
to end up being uh digitized for sure if
you look at china i think roughly 20 of
their population is unbanked which
sounds crazy but 20 and they're they
have 1.4 billion people in china so call
it you know all nearly 300 million
people are unbanked in their country
which is almost the size of the united
states for comparison right the pro case
for a central bank digital currency is
that this gives access to people that
potentially might not have access to
a bank or a currency system or or just
kind of the financial infrastructure
that it does now
ultimately i think that's a trade-off
between security and all these other
things right but do you think that's
like a happy medium approach and
ultimately that transitions people more
people to bitcoin and other assets like
that or do you think it's just a
terrible idea altogether and the
unbanked people should should find these
assets on their own i think that what's
going to happen is as all these
currencies get digitized the
nation-states are going to drive
adoption of digital wallets and once you
drive adoption of a digital wallet value
will flow to the strongest soundest
money as a store of value and then there
will still be requirements to use uh
specific fiat currencies right whether
it's the dollar to pay taxes uh
or merchants will accept certain
currencies or whatever but i do think
that that's the uh way that most people
are gonna get onboarded you know get to
100 million people or so without the
nation states but in order to go from
100 million to 7 billion i think what's
going to end up happening is uh the
nation states believe their ability to
compete in the marketplace is that they
have a monopoly on uh monetary policy
and the production and distribution of
the fiat currencies and so what they're
going to say is oh you guys want digital
currencies great we're going to digitize
our currency keep the same monetary
policy let's get that into your hands
but when they do that they're going to
drive adoption of the digital wallet in
a way that the private sector couldn't
do alone and when they go ahead and they
drive that adoption of digital wallets
then all of a sudden people are sitting
there and saying okay now that my
switching cost between all these assets
is near zero and so the weak currencies
are going to actually accelerate their
own demise the strong fiat currencies
will actually be a beneficiary because
the weak currencies fail uh or less
popular and then ultimately something
like a bitcoin all it needs is more
people with digital wallets and
uh value naturally floats kind of like
on an exchange right like liquidity but
gets liquidity if there's an exchange
with uh a dominant amount of liquidity
everyone starts to trade there and it
locks in like a network effect and it
becomes just so dominant that you can't
unseat it same thing happens here is
once you start to get uh a store of
value i think a lot about like store
value but get store of value so if
people start to use something as a store
of value and then as that works more
people see that they begin to store
about and then all of a sudden you just
have this network effect where uh it
ends up serving as a better and better
store value over time gold did that for
a really long time for literally
thousands of years and so just like
liquidity uh but gets liquidity store
value but gets a store of value and
ultimately what the fiat currencies are
going to end up doing is dominating as a
medium of exchange in the short term and
something like a bitcoin i think as it
has over the last 12 years has been the
single best store value that you could
possibly hold and people are waking up
to that they're getting educated on that
they're realizing okay it started out
with that's a crazy idea then it was
like one percent then it was three
percent it was five percent of their
portfolio and now i think you've got an
entire generation of young people who
are growing up and they're saying to
themselves why do i not have majority of
my net worth in sound money
right and it's not a question of uh what
is the financial gain from like a
percentage basis against the dollar it's
simply how do i protect my purchasing
power in a high inflationary environment
i think that's ultimately where you know
you're starting to see separation uh
from the generations where the old older
generation they know that the holding
the dollar doesn't make sense radalio
cashes trash all that
their solution is not to find a better
savings tool their solution is to go
risk money in the market and to try to
outpace with their financial returns the
inflation yeah but what young people are
realizing is like hey that's a fool's
game to many people and so instead why
don't i just save in a better savings
technology right and then oh by the way
i don't think of it in terms of what's
the us dollar value for it i just think
of it in terms of bitcoin right how much
bitcoin do i have i just look at okay
today i have x number of satoshi's how
many do i have tomorrow and the day
after that and the day after that and
there's no coming back out of it because
it's technically a savings tool that
they're looking at over decades and that
return of long-term thinking is in
direct opposition to the short-term
thinking that's driven by fiat currency
and the fiat currency is the constant
feeling of never being able to get ahead
right you're you're the rat on the wheel
you're just running and running and
running and every time you use like oh
man i got a two percent raise at work i
got a four percent raise at work got a
five percent raise at work but
everything got more expensive around me
how the hell is it that my rent's going
up my mortgage payments going up uh my
cost of uh groceries is going up when i
go to a restaurant it's going up like i
can't catch up
and so you constantly feel like you're
falling ahead uh behind and when you
feel like you're falling behind it gives
you short-term thinking and when you
have short-term thinking you end up
making bad decisions when you then go
and you start to save in a sound money
technology like bitcoin now all of a
sudden everything's getting less
expensive around you right that rent
payment that grocery bill that
restaurant bill everything is getting
less and less expensive over time
because the asset is outpacing the
actual increase of prices and when you
do that now you can have a long-term
thinking you actually don't want to make
short-term decisions because the
short-term decisions will in hindsight
look financially stupid because you
basically took the bitcoin you bought
you know an 80-inch screen tv and you're
like man i'm balling and then you're
like damn that 800 that i spent in
bitcoin in 2014 to buy the 80-inch
screen tv is now worth you know whatever
a million bucks a 100k whatever the
numbers end up being and so you start to
say yourself wait a second i have to
think long term because of the way the
asset is built and so ultimately what
you get is you get two different
perspectives those two different
perspectives are driven by the monetary
structure of the assets and when you
have a difference in monetary structure
what you get is you get a different
level of decision making and so monetary
structure drives perspective perspective
drives action and so now what we're
literally doing is you're basically
handing an entire generation of people a
brand new asset that they can save in
that they think long term they don't
make stupid financial decisions and my
guess is that the bitcoiners aren't
going to have the same financial
troubles that people 40 and over have in
terms of having incredibly high levels
of debt uh not having money for
retirement like all these issues that uh
the 40 and older crowd has is all driven
by the fiat currency forcing them to
make short-term decisions and it
literally incentivizes you to take on
more debt it incentivizes you to do this
stuff whereas the sound money doesn't do
that and i think that's ultimately like
the true uh impact of this asset is when
you hand this to a population globally
you're going to change the world but
you're not going to change the world in
you know kind of the woo silicon valley
way you're going to change the world
because you're quite literally going to
change the perspective of people when
you change their perspective and make
them long-term thinkers you change their
actions and what it does is it
ultimately pulls all the people in the
bottom half of that wealth disparity gap
you pull them back up closer to the top
because now every single person whether
you're michael sailor with 120 000
bitcoin or you literally have five
satoshi's you mean the exact same to the
network you have no extra control uh
regardless of how much you have you have
no extra say there's no uh cantalonian
effect there's none of that stuff it's
just if you hold bitcoin you get the
same exact protection and you get the
same exact treatment from the network
regardless of how much you have and so
then it comes down to what percentage of
your net worth are you actually
protecting with this asset right if
michael saylor had the ability to buy
500 000 bitcoin they only bought 120 000
right let's just say on average about uh
20 of his wealth and you have less money
but you protect 100 of your net worth
right you actually have more protection
than michael saylor has because you've
been able to convert more on a
percentage basis than he has the numbers
are different but you're treated exactly
the same by the network and that's the
key piece is that there's an equal
opportunity for economic protection by
bitcoin and by a decentralized computing
network now and anyone in the world
whether you're the largest asset manager
you're a nation state or you're
literally a pleb sitting in your
basement hoping that your mom brings you
some ice cream downstairs you get
protected by the bitcoin network the
exact same and that's the beauty of this
whole thing